throughout her career lizzo has been
outspoken about body positivity and has
built a lucrative Empire while doing so
she has designed okay so she's saying
she's she's not about body positivity
okay but let's look at this is why you
can't listen to things that women say
because you have to watch what we do and
she then then has a shapewear line
called Yeti which is designed for all
body shapes what is shapewear do it
holds in your blubber like if I had
shapewear right now I would look like I
had a six-pack it would be like a it's
literally like if you're so body
positive why do you need to pull in the
blubber be positive put it all out there
don't suck it in